I love singing dancing hi folks  [Music]  [Applause]  50 Cent's out suck your dick well it's a  great price it almost makes me wish I  had a dick for you to suck or take that  is yes you were the most decorated  officers in this department what do you  see  robbery gone wrong to me this wasn't a  robbery this was a hit out there killing  puppet I'm a woman that's okay good time  for you we're gonna catch the bastards  who did these murders because bodies are  gonna start piling up doing the best  damn cops I've ever seen I'll have your  badge for this I'm in the [ __ ] FBI oh  yeah  [Music]  yeah God are you alright diamond if your  exist I'm not doing this do it oh sorry  about your dead human friend Phillip  [Music]  he's filling he's servicing implying is  that what I think it is  [Music]  [Music]